hi everyone it's joanna here are you
excited for another workout session
today's workout is going to be a full
body strength training workout so we
will be working on our legs our upper
body as well as our car and the good
news is it's low impact so
no jumping at all
i want you to finish this workout
feeling strong
let's do this
[Music]
so let's start with a quick warm-up okay
so what i'm going to do is stand
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointer forward place both arms behind
your head keeping your legs straight
just slightly bend from your hips and
straighten back up and squeeze your
glutes so this is a good morning stretch
you should feel it on your hamstrings
and squeeze your glutes as you come back
up all right so the key is to keep your
legs straight if you can't you can have
a slight bend on your knees but feel the
stretch in your hamstrings and squeeze
back up good
feel more
keeping your back flat up squeeze your
glutes
back flat
squeeze let's stretch our muscles out
one more
and
up squeeze good job all right
let's go with in and out squats alright
so
feet together squat down
step out
and squat back down ooh can you hear
that click
that is my
legs working good let's go squat down
as low as you can this is still a warm
up so i want you to go nice and easy
feet together feet out remember to
always point your toes forward push your
butt down
back flat
and squat good one more on each side
remember chest up
face forward okay
always keep a neutral position
one more
and come back up alright now face
forward let's take a forward and back
lunge so let's start with the left leg
step wide forward
tap
step back
and tap
so you should feel the work on your legs
and also the stretch on your hip flexor
just working on one
side to begin with step back
in
and forward
good now change leg
right leg forward
back
and good there you go i want you to also
start to engage your car
and find your balance
we will be needing that
later on in the workout tap step forward
tap
back
one more
forward
tap
and back all right now just face forward
feel hip rotation
let's open up the hips
good job
big hip rotation
opposite side
you should feel your body warmed up
right now so the first circuit is going
to be a lower body circuit okay so we
want to start wide so step wide into a
wide squat position toes pointed out and
this workout is going to work on your
outer glutes as well as your inner
thighs as you come down
lift your heels off the floor there you
go okay so alternate heel lift
with
a wide squat go low
heels up good job there you go feel the
stretch on your inner thighs
feel the work
on your outer glutes
go as slow as you can push it out
good push your knees
out
and breathe your core
stand tall
keep going
and breathe out as you come up okay
one heel at a time
that's one more
and come back up all right good job
still working on our legs our glutes as
well as our hamstrings cutsy lunge to a
side raise so stand straight up with the
putt with your toes pointer forward
lunge
cross take a step
and up and squeeze your glutes okay so
cross over
tap
up
and tap
good job there you go tap find your
balance and tap
step
just a gentle tab do not rest your feet
now let's bring the speed up slightly
squeeze
and back so you should feel your right
glute working and as you raise your left
leg up you should feel the squeeze on
your left glute as well remember that
your knees should be pointing
forward okay
up
so hips forward
do not rotate tap
and up
brace your core tighten your core
and
up good job so let's work on the other
leg again hips facing forward do not
rotate your hips to the side hips facing
forward
arms just right in front of you brace
your core take your opposite leg back
tap
ah okay i want you to try to lunge as
low as you can if you can
get your knees to tap the floor and come
back
up good job so push it out
good down
and up remember as you push up push
through your heels
good down
squeeze it
track down
and up
look straight ahead
and just remember to always pace your
breathing
back and up
feel the work
on the other leg
good remember as you squeeze up hold for
one count and bring it back down
up very good all right next is going to
be a knee driver lunge with a twist okay
still working on single leg and we want
to make sure that both legs are equally
balanced okay so take a step back as you
lunge up twist
tap step back and twist if you need to
reset
step back and twist if not
step back
twist
back
and twist good job there you go twist
this is one of my
favorite
workouts
i love this because it really hits the
glutes
and
also i'm working on my core at the same
time
twist
back
twist good find your balance
brace your core
working on your right leg
keep going down and up twist that back
and twist all right good job now let's
change the other side okay so
right leg step back
take the time to breathe ready break
your core suck the belly in arms up
let's go guys
twist
find your balance
look at one point
try to launch as low as you can
into a 90 degree position and twist
good job strong core strong legs
you got this
and twist
remember to drive a knee
to your elbow so drive your knee as high
as you can if you need to you can take a
step reset step back and twist all right
so choose your option
twist good job
working on the sexy waistline as well
twist that's one more
and just shake it out all right guess
what we're going to repeat the entire
round once more okay so remember we're
starting
wide take a wide
squat position
alternate heel leaves so arms in front
as you come down wrist one heel
off the floor and i want you to really
push
and go low
good
go low
really feel the stretch on your inner
thighs
and push up
and feel the work on the outer glutes
okay knees
pointing out
and i'm gonna add a little bit of
challenge towards the end
one more
and now i want you to stay on both toes
let's go small pulses
only 10 seconds
feel that burn on your inner thighs your
quads and your glutes keep going
ah
well done okay
curtsy lunge with a side leg raise okay
so
start in the middle hips
facing forward remember curtsy cross
over
tap
raise it to the side
do not rush the workout what's more
important is that
you feel the right muscle engaged
and
your form is perfect okay so down all
the way down
all the way up
all the way down
and all the way up good job
there you go tap
remember it's just a slight tap it's not
a long rest in between the transition
good job cross
and up
very good you are looking strong
keep going
down
up straight legs squeeze and back down
okay shake it out a little bit change
the other side okay
so again hips facing forward
keep a slight bend in your knees and
let's go arms up cross over
tap
squeeze and down
cross
tap
and up good job
okay brace your core
use the strength from your left leg to
really balance
your body
engage that muscle okay up squeeze good
job
right here okay up and squeeze
very good down
up tap
and down
good keep going you're strong
tap
up
can you feel left leg burning i can
let's keep going you're almost there
two more reps step out
last one more give me one more
up and back down okay
knee driver with a twist okay
so this is a reverse lunge
again
start in a neutral position arms up
brace your core suck your belly in let's
go
step back and twist
step back and twist if you want you can
drop
the opposite
arm
twist knee to elbow twist
feel the work on your right
glute to begin with
take a wide step back
and twist
good job
very good keep going
working on the obliques
twist
the waistline come on let's go
i know your leg is burning your right
leg but let's not stop right now
one more
all right let's change the other side
okay now
right leg step back okay i'm gonna turn
the other way right leg step back
and twist on the left side ready arms up
raise your core let's go up
twist
step back
and rotate
good if you can't go as high that's fine
okay
go
at
your comfort level
good
keep going
and remember as you repeat this workout
you want to push yourself that little
bit further okay
take it up a notch every time you do
this workout and that is how you get
stronger
good good [ __ ]
i can feel my heart rate
and guess what
right after this
you're going to get a one
minute break last one more
give me another one
and
oh
sweaty
take a shot one minute break
grab your mat if you have one
and we want to give our lower body a
rest and work on our
upper body our arms shoulders as well as
our back muscles okay so keep yourself
hydrated
for the next two circuits we will be
working on the mat alright so the first
circuit is going to be an upper body
circuit that will be push-ups because
push-up will get your upper body really
strong so let's start with the first
exercise which is going to be a plank up
down and a front raise so here's a tip
if you find yourself sliding off the mat
what you can do is place a tower
directly underneath you and start
and place your elbows onto the towel
okay so start in a plank position push
yourself up
shoulders
front raise back down
raise your core push yourself up
and front raise all right
i want you to really make sure that your
hips are not rotating to the left or to
the right so if you find yourself doing
this
this is wrong
brace your core and really keep your
hips in place
and try to bring your arms as high as
possible the higher it goes the more you
will feel the work on your shoulders
push yourself up
front raise
good there you go
back down up
strong core
keeping your legs straight and your back
straight
very good okay
next
is going to be a white and a narrow
push-up so what's the difference white
push-ups were hit more on your chest
muscles whereas narrow will target your
triceps okay so we'll do this on our
knees so start in a wide push-up
position
go down elbows out
back in elbows
pointed back okay so out again
and in
and elbows pointed back the narrow
push-up will be more challenging
good job
so remember to the goal is to bring your
chest as low as you can
towards the floor
and still keeping your back
in a straight line so do not pike your
butt up
this is wrong okay back flat
down
back in
narrow elbows pointed back
good job
one more
and
in all right now lie straight onto
your back the next workout is going to
be a superman and a back squeeze so i
want you to just focus on your upper
body so just relax your legs
get into a superman and squeeze your
back
hold for one count and back down okay up
squeeze your back
release
back down
good job
and back down you should feel your back
your trap muscles and even the back of
your shoulders
up
squeeze hold it
and release
this is not an easy workout even without
weights you will really feel the work up
squeeze elbows pointing back
working on the lats the traps
and
the rear delts
good job
squeeze
back
and
one more
very good okay
are we ready for the plank up down with
a front raise
let's do it okay so choose your option
with or without the towel so start in a
plank position
push yourself up left
and right
and the tip here is if you're struggling
to find a balance keep your feet wider
apart okay
that will give you a better foundation
up
up
and slowly back down do not collapse one
step at a time
back down
push yourself up
front raise
strong arms
strong shoulders
breathe out
good job
few more
do not rotate your hips
minimum movement coming from the hips
down
and just drop your knees okay
love it i headed i want you to start
adding push-ups into your workout let's
go start in a wide push-up position so
your palms should be wider slightly
wider than your shoulders alright on
your knees let's go one push up
back in narrow
and elbows pointing back wide
back in
and
down good job
remember with never push up you're using
the strength from your triceps push
yourself back up
good job
so the goal is to lower yourself down
and push yourself up in one straight
line
good job raise your core keep your back
flat down and up
go wide
and narrow
not easy you're doing a great job
keep going
strong
and up okay
right
final upper body workout let's lie flat
down
again just spread your feet slightly
apart relax your lower body focus on
your upper body arm straight superman
squeeze
and drop
so i want to try to go as high as you
can
gaze onto the floor
keep a neutral neck and really work
on your back
good
let's bring
sexy back let's go squeeze it good job
elbows pointing back
drive your shoulder blades together
and release
and if you want to challenge yourself
all you need to do is grab
really light pair of dumbbells even one
kilo is enough to really
kill your shoulders traps and back a few
more
up
squeeze
down and release
okay
oh my gosh can you believe that that is
the end of our upper body circuit it
went by so quickly so take a shot one
minute break and the final round is
going to be on our core muscles alright
so take a short break
[Music]
final circuit for this total body
strength training workout okay
core workout our favorite planks all
right so let's start on
in get let's get into a plank position
okay this is your basic plank position
what i want you to do is to challenge
your core a little bit more by dropping
your knees
onto the floor just a slight tap
and that imbalance will make your core
work even harder okay so if you find
this difficult what you can do is start
in a high plank position and just tap
one knee
at a time okay just a slight tap do not
rest it
and the goal here is to create that
slight imbalance and to challenge your
core even more if you want to go low
single knee tap all right
you know the challenge that's coming up
we want to go for double knee taps okay
let's go double knee tap up tap up okay
do not rush through the workout really
breathe your core suck your belly in
drop the knees and back up
nice and controlled good job there you
go up
last one more down up and
drop it down
that burn in your core
that's what we want okay now let's get
into a high plank position this is to
work on your obliques so high plank
and it's going to be a spiderman out
and a cross
plank okay so it's a combo out
out
cross
and cross
so again the focus here
is to work
on your obliques
good job
stay strong
cross
and cross
try to drive your knee towards your
elbow okay
but still keeping your back
flat
push into the ground
strong shoulders as well cross
cross
good
that's one more
cross
one more wrap
and just drop it back down okay
now
sit on your butt
the next workout is going to be a knee
and a v tax this really focuses more on
the lower abs but you will also feel on
your overall abs so just support your
upper body
knee tuck
v tucks okay knee
v
if the v tuck is too difficult you can
just keep it to a knee tuck all right
knee
v
good
job raise your core
balance yourself
up
down
up
and in
straight legs as straight as you can
i have tight hamstrings
up
in
up
and in
one more up
and in
and just drop it down okay
guess what guys
we want to repeat the entire circuit
once more and this is your final three
minute workout okay so
catch your breath breathe in let's start
choose your option either a high plank
single knee tap
okay
brace your core
or
if you want to
let's get low
single
knee taps to begin with
left and right
left and right okay
good job stay strong
halfway there
let's go double
control up squeeze control up
raise your core flat back
down and up
brace it feel the squeeze
breathe out as you drive your knees up
last one
and just drop it down
oh my god
it is
raining in here
who says that strength training doesn't
help you to burn calories it does and
strength training even help you to boost
your metabolism so you will be burning
fat at the same time okay
all right now let's work on our obliques
high plank
spiderman
cross
spider
and cross
keep going
give me your best effort
let's keep it up to the beat
cross
and cross
out
cross over
knee to elbow
push into the ground
let's not stop right now
that's two more i can feel your burn
and back down
okay
now
let's
sit on our butt guys
oh
final 45 seconds of workout my arms are
dying my core is absolutely on fire but
let's finish this strung together okay
so place your palms down relax your
upper body
knee tucks v
and knee
remember to pace your breathing
find your rhythm
keep going
nice
if you're struggling instead of stopping
what you can do is to single leg
and single leg
up okay if not stay with me last few
more reps
up
last one more
up and just lower yourself down and rest
it out
i am
absolutely
i'm feeling strong
i'm feeling tired but i've known i done
i've done a great job okay so just take
this time to really
bring your heart rate back down
get into a child's pose
stretch your entire body out
okay
you've done a great job this is your
time to just relax
and stretch it out
and just breathe
and bring your heart rate back down
good and now get into
a baby cobra okay so palms by your chest
push yourself up
and remember to push the shoulders away
from your body and just look as far back
as you can
feel the stretch on your lower back
your core
and your arms as well stretch it out
good job
and now push yourself up
into a downward
dark position
all right try to bring your heels
towards the floor if you can't you can
also walk the dog
all right
just work it out
bend your knee
and just
really push into the floor
good job
keep pushing
you want to create that high mountain
okay
keep pushing
and now slowly drop your knees
and what i'm going to do is bring your
left leg forward
and just sink your hips
into the floor and feel the stretch on
your hip flexor
as well as your glutes okay so remember
push
forward
and now let's add a little bit of side
twist
good job
and breathe
and now change
left leg back right leg forward
again it's not this it's dropping your
hips down
feel that stretch right here
and twist
good job
and just breathe
and now just slowly
come back up
all right
just stretch your arms forward
a slight shoulder stretch
change
the other side
and slowly
come back up okay
all right guys
that is the end of a 30 minute total
body strength training i am sweating i
am feeling strong do this workout at
least three times a week to boost your
metabolism to increase your muscle mass
and also to burn fat okay and don't
forget to combine this workout with my
other workouts on youtube and do check
out a lot more meal plans full workout
plans as well as fitness tips on my
youtube channel and i will see you next
time let me know in the comments below
how you felt and if you're
glowing like me all the best